[Applause]
style bender
took an l uh trying to get his second
belt he came up to 205 to fight the
champ jan blehovich yeah
uh forgive me on if i'm not pronouncing
your [ __ ] name right but um
name's stupid so he was nice though
he is and izzy even said it afterwards
he was like he's if i have to lose with
somebody he's a great champ
he's gracious he's sweet like it's so
weird
there are some people that need to get
themselves so hyped for those fights
that the person in front of them they
have to literally want to kill
yeah right but jan seems like this guy
like
he doesn't seem like he'd fight dirty
seems like he's gonna fight by the rules
he understands it's the fight game he's
gonna try and knock you out
yeah but he doesn't seem like the guy
who would like hold you in a choke
longer than he needs to
or punch you one extra time after you're
down just because
yeah and there are [ __ ] in mma
that like they will choke you out you're
tapping and they hold that [ __ ]
until the ref stops right there are
people who see somebody unconscious on
the floor and then jump on top
four so he seems like this sweet kind of
nice guy and he fought a [ __ ]
brilliant fight against izzy he really
did
like he was ready for the leg kicks yeah
you know um izzy was trying to catch him
with that question mark
yeah over and over again he was able to
block uh block it
and um he beat is he fair and square
yeah
and it's a bummer obviously because
that's our guy
yeah you know i spoke to him he said
he's doing good you know it is what it
is
like he said uh you know like he was
saying dare to be great and yeah you
should be great like right
the guy is coming up 20 pounds
yeah right to go fight the guy who is
the champ
who's been knocking people to [ __ ] out
and as far as i saw i didn't see
is he hurt one time during the fight no
the guy used his weight well stayed on
top of him yeah and that was it but
but he landed punches on is he oh yeah
but i didn't see izzy get stumbled like
he was able to handle the power and yon
was just concussing people
yeah like one punch knockout okay the
last few fighters
i don't know if you saw last couple of
his fights i i think i've seen one
but he was just cussing 220 pound guys
yeah
big big boys big boys and he's getting
into that ring at like 240 and is he
staying 200 probably
yeah i don't know about 240 that'd be a
lot of weight to put on i don't know i'm
throwing out numbers 205 is where they
fight at
so usually you could probably maybe add
like another 15 pounds
i'm an idiot i thought the fight was at
220 and then no no 205.
185 is what izzy usually fights at two
or five square fights
so so yeah so this is there's a couple
things that are going on here obviously
i'm [ __ ] biased i want izzy to win
you know but
he did get out pointed he he got
i thought that jan striking was
phenomenal izzy's one of the best
strikers in the history of mma
right and jan was able to strike with
him effectively yeah is he landing his
shots obviously rocked him a couple
times i thought one time he had him hurt
but jan was able to be in there and jan
landed a couple shots
i thought izzy was going to absolutely
dominate him with the striking
but jan was going to be big to the point
where if he landed it could hurt izzy
and it wasn't it wasn't the case jan was
effective with the striking
right so what i think happened was
um is in a weird way and i know you're
going to go oh you just capping for your
boy blah blah i don't care
i think this is the best case scenario
for izzy fighting at 185 pounds
right i think this is best case scenario
for a couple things right one
where he's dominant at is 185 pounds
and there's a couple reasons why he's
dominant one he just happens to be the
best in the world at 185 pounds right
but he can use some of his advantages at
185 pounds that he doesn't exactly have
at 205 with those bigger guys
right at 185 he's significantly taller
and longer than these guys
so what izzy can do is he can hop in
punching and kicking range and hop
out of punching a kicking range whatever
he wants while also being out of the
range of the person he's fighting
right right so if you've noticed a few
of his last like knockouts like i've
noticed they come from these
these lean back hooks have you seen it
like
he can he dropped costa with that lean
back hook he dropped um
what's the other australian guy that he
put robert whittaker with that lean back
hook like
he just kind of he exchanges he throws
his combination and he leans away from
their strike
while throwing this kind of like up left
hook it's a really odd punch
right but super effective it's harder to
do that against a taller longer opponent
because you have to commit yourself to
being in a danger zone more
than you do against a smaller opponent
right so he's got to take more fights
at that weight where you're fighting
guys that height so he could learn how
to be effective in his striking right
without putting himself in too dangerous
or too precarious a situation okay
right but what i love about this is the
last fight he had at 185 when he took
out costa that bum
he would he destroyed him to a point
where at least i was going there's
nobody interesting for him to fight at
185
right like he's too dominant right
it's the khabib thing yeah like we don't
need to see khabib fight dustin poirier
again
god bless doesn't porya but khabib
dominated him
so it's not interesting to see him fight
him again right he was too dominant and
all of a sudden you start to lose
interest in the fights
when people are too dominant right him
losing to yon
puts a battery in everybody at 185's
back
okay they're all going oh [ __ ] all you
gotta do is take him down
yeah oh oh if you get him down then you
can control him right yeah
i i want you to try that okay i want you
to try
to get into grappling range with izzy
bees he's gonna piece you up and he's
gonna sit you the [ __ ] down right
right so i think this is good because it
really heightens the interest at 185
again where there was
none at all and that's the division
where you wanted to see him dominate
he if he if he knocks out i think he's
going to fight uh
darren till next okay if darren till
beats this uh
marvin vittori guy okay and him against
darren till is going to be the most fun
that we've ever had in a fight build up
on social media they're both
exceptional at social media this guy
darren till is very funny on social okay
very funny right he's funny in
interviews and
the two of them going at it together in
the hype of the build-up to the fight
also they both finally [ __ ] speak
english yeah i've been telling izzy this
for his entire career stop fighting
these guys who don't speak english right
you gotta do all the promoting of the
[ __ ] fight
yeah you're gonna fight against a guy
who speaks english he can promote it to
all the fans that also understand
english
in a really funny effective way that
fight he's got to get by this marvin
vittorio guy but that
is a super fight i would be so excited
to see that fight
yeah and um ideally there's fans back in
there
etc so i i think this is very good for
izzy at 185
yeah here's the problem
if jon jones goes and wins
the heavyweight belt by beating the
winner of inganu versus
uh stipe mm-hmm jon jones
has something over izzy which is jones
went up and wait
won a belt okay izzy went up in weight
and he lost
the 205 chance that's not to say that
izzy can't go up and do it again
but if john is effective then
he has something over izzy as the
current goat in the sport
right right so that's up to you let's
see what happens i mean jon jones could
get
caught yeah by one of those big boys and
then
completely knocked out and then izzy got
something over john right he's like you
went
up and wait you got your ass knocked the
[ __ ] out that being said jon jones is a
very good wrestler
and if izzy struggled with yon
wrestling jan isn't a wrestler but he's
black belt jiu jitsu he's a good ground
game
but he would struggle with john right so
it is it is just an interesting thing
now
john doesn't have the power that jan has
right
so izzy's gonna go trade with john okay
if they keep it on the feet
is he after feeling yon's power and not
getting dropped he's like oh i'm ready
i'm ready for these 205 it's like i
wonder if izzy right now i really want
to talk to him on the pod is he come on
a pod already man
i wonder if after after engaging with
yon and not getting hurt if he's like
i should have just stood in there with
that [ __ ] right because when he
exchanged with him there was one more
where he caught yon with a left hook and
jan hid
the fact that he was hurt well but in
the replay you see him get staggered
and kind of walking around i think if
izzy knew how badly he was hurt he would
have put on a sauce
yeah he just didn't want to get exposed
he didn't want to get you you mean he
didn't want to get uh
caught yeah like he can counter so well
but if he you know if he gets caught
because the guy has concussive power
yeah and i think by the end of the fight
is he starting to realize he's caught me
clean
yeah a few times i can eat some of these
and i ate them yeah
so i i mean i would even like to see
them go at it again
maybe later on yeah and maybe it's a
different fight but also you could argue
that yawn would be like i'm not even
striking with this guy i'm gonna take
him down
and if he doesn't improve his take down
defense or doesn't improve his ability
to get back
up when he's been taken down i'm just
going to hold him down there right which
is what yon did yohan didn't do damage
when he had him on the ground he just
held him he held him yeah
and that's on izzy is he got to be able
to get up from that
yeah and ideally he learns
etc and kind of improves that part of
the game but yeah go you can correct me
if i'm wrong so can izzy
i thought i'm watching the fight worried
for izzy i thought he got caught
caught a couple times in the third round
maybe and then he got a little bit
uh shook from it not shook but like he
got a little more affected than
not feeling it at all and i thought
that's where he started to lose the
fight and that's why i don't remember at
the
like i felt like that's where it he got
a little more loose with how he was
playing and then he was able to get
taken down
does that make any sense i'm watching a
complete amateur he looked tired he was
saying he was tired but i would say
towards the end
like towards end i think he was doing
this like kind of like flow thing
yeah right but i think that was masking
him just being being tired and you know
what
i'd be tired too if i was carrying
another 20 pounds with me
yeah he usually fights to 185 and he
fights around his weight
he weighs into 185 i don't think he
gains more than five pounds for a fight
afterwards
so imagine you're carrying an extra 15
pounds
around for a five-round fight that's
different right like had the round of
trying to get up
from him you're being held down
after the fourth round takedown it was
you know i would say even the first
takedown is what
that was in the fourth round i think
right fourth and fifth the first take
down
he got up from one oh i thought it was
earlier in the i thought it was maybe
but i think that was a big part of the
reason what like gaston
yeah he usually is good to go for five
rounds oh he's got
yeah he got energy forever so it was
interesting to see but it is a different
level of energy like when you're
carrying around more weight
yeah every clinch is different that's a
good point you know and you're also
thinking differently it was
i don't know i know it seems like i'm
capping for izzy but i really feel like
four interest in 185 pound fights this
is the best thing
right in order to promote fights you
need to think the other guy has a chance
yeah like remember when mayweather
fights start to get boring he was
fighting carlos baldomir
the guy actually went to that fight in
vegas but like he's fighting these guys
you're like there's no way that
mayweather can lose to this guy yeah so
what's the point of me watching and then
mayweather had to turn heel
so hard right he had to become the
villain so bad that you just bought it
hoping he would lose right you know what
i mean yeah right i don't know if
he wants to do that like i don't know if
he wants to be like a villain like that
no no
and like it's not his brand yeah it's
like he's like
he's weird he's like a he's kind of like
he's like the joker
like he's not a villain but he's not a
good guy no
right he'll knock you out and hump you
yeah you know what i mean
captain america ain't doing that yeah so
he's got he's mischievous
yeah yeah he's mischie he's loki yeah
yeah yeah right like
you know what i'm saying he's not thor
but he's not he's loki he's not a bad
guy
completely but he's not a good guy
completely yeah yeah and it's relatable
because if someone's talking [ __ ] to you
and you knock them out you want to hump
them too
yeah you don't got to do that good guy
[ __ ] handshake nonsense get a stroke
going
let's go yeah that's what it is yo
izzy's got to know what you sacrificed
to watch his fights bro
yo that's true man we had when was it we
were in salt lake
yeah and we i was about to go on yo like
on stage
so i just had mark go longer yeah
this man is mad stressed in the green
room pacing around like come on izzy oh
you do
i don't think you understand this but
like i get so nervous i was super
nervous
bro there's a crowd of people sitting in
salt lake city so excited to see their
favorite comedian that's packed out
all these people in there the guy comes
in he's like you're ready to start
you're like yeah we could wait three
four minutes you know
and he's just sitting in there anxious
as [ __ ] sitting on the ground everyone's
sitting on the couch he's just sitting
on the ground
i'm so nervous i'm shaking i
i i actually shake this is with with
fights where like i'm invested in a
fighter
i shake and i'm so nervous and
i literally am thinking i just can't
wait for this fight to be over so i can
calm down and go on stage in front of
people and talk
bro people are changing his name and
drew yeah true drew andrew's in a fetal
position in the green room
terrified for izzy isn't that crazy i'm
way more terrified of a fight
that i have zero control that's why
you're terrified yeah i guess because
you have no control over it but still
like most people their greatest fear is
speaking in front of strangers yeah
we're in a theater full of people in
boston you're like hanging out taking
pictures with people having a good time
you watch izzy fight and you're [ __ ]
i am a scallop and it takes a second
like when i go on stage i gotta like
loosen up a little bit because i'm
so tensed yeah just from watching it
they got to put these fights in an
afternoon you know what i mean i it
can't be this late night thing where
you're competing with your own show
the only thing i'm bummed about is that
we're probably never gonna get the jon
jones fight
i think we will still i think it will be
later on i think if jon loses to one of
those heavyweights
it's happening it's guaranteed like it's
guaranteed they both get humbled
they could both talk [ __ ] john goes into
the fight going i'm just gonna take this
guy down
uh izzy goes in the fight going i could
take any punch from that [ __ ]
laying clean as often as you want i took
clean shots from
one of the hardest hitters at 205. ate
it so i'm stepping in there
i'm exchanging with you it's on
so i think i think we get it i guess we
gotta
hope that stipe or francis knocks out
john
also if one of them knocks out john like
if francis in ghana goes in there with
jon jones
that's not a decision yep like john
might be able to beat him by decision
but if francis wins that fight it's
night night
yeah and if he gets knocked out
violently
oh is he gonna have a field jay on it
i cannot wait
you